hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay we're
going into this foggy shadowy part
there's probably bad idea okay okay I
like this
George ridin do you yeah yeah yeah yeah
want none of this
wait there's nothing in here what's
going on is we got a whole bunch of
nothing it's just a big room and big
empty room what the hell is going on
hello bite you you have the answers
oh oh oh you made friends Oh what you
want some too
a whole you look it oh no a chair
Oh what what what oh uh Glee on if
you're ugly
yeah hide your shame all right it's
still just a big empty room wait it's a
little smaller
this isn't that scary I mean it's just a
big empty room
oh that candelabras upset Wow and now
sideways and you made more friends
there's nine of you huh
Wow turn up soldier pay attention I'm
your commander now listen when I talk to
you oh there's some sass bar yeah huh oh
you're okay but you like a problems with
you the room is getting smaller the
candelabra is going sideways and there's
more these guys not scary well hello
there it goes again
huh guy what do you think you're doing
sneaking up on me like that huh huh you
all fight me oh you couldn't handle me
huh
your face is kind of weird I never
really looked at you that's actually
kind of disturbing okay
anyway the room is smaller now
definitely and there's only one of the
guy now
like I said before not scary just kind
of weird I guess what why are you yeah
you stare at the ground oh hey yeah
that's right line up and salute salute
me okay candelabra Oh get out
no you get out douche Oh what are you
are you Ted no Billy no I wear okay whoa
I went sideways okay what was the point
of this can you move
oh there there wait am I just what was
the point of that tell me to get out I
was weird wasn't even like really scary
or anything but I mean it was just like
I don't know a few startles but nothing
big not even really startles just ER ah
and then gone all right whatever then um
spiral staircase that's going up from
the number four gate and it goes all the
way over there too like her face oh yeah
gonna go run up and give her a big kiss
on yeah okay number one let me see
what's behind door number one
Oh monsters death and dismemberment oh
my favorite
alright up a chair oh it's okay you
don't need to bow before me I know I'm I
know I'm great but yeah you really don't
have too much hair you just flipping out
all over the place up again it's getting
normal you silly Willy get ah ha ha oh
thank you for just not not going crazy
in my presence anyway alright
anyway hey oye up tinder box okay never
mind
Oh chair what are you doing oh oh hello
dear diary my mommy locked the metal
door with the key mommy never says where
the key is
my mommy hide it somewhere come on kid
really oh oh it's it's a mini door it's
a locked mini door look at it isn't any
bitty door just like that door it's tiny
oh look you
books buxter your books
okay lay up there no okay oh oh excuse
me ma'am bar you thank you at all thank
you very much
anything in there no Gigantor just a
note that big chest for job wouldn't
give me that I don't know how you opened
it opened it maybe my husband helped you
out but if it is an emergency I place
the key behind one of the books in the
bedroom but don't go to the basement one
of the workers is locked out locked in
he was haunted by something I don't know
I just hope you don't need to open it I
hope I don't either but I'm just
following blind directions I don't even
know what direction I'm following
okay bookshelf in the bedroom this is
obviously isn't a bedroom but let me
check anyway
nope nothing all right that's fine ah a
chair was murdered did you see what
happened are you okay let me get you a
nice and straight there all right um if
you mind there no okay only one secret
paintings I got a knife finally I got a
weapon yeah bringing our monsters what
you got
Oh huh I think in the fire anything
above the fireplace no oh sorry chair
I'm sorry about that whoops whoa whoa
come on get straight come on turn chair
don't dick around with me what what what
jerk lame stop breakdancing we got
business to do you really you're just
gonna break down here and okay there we
go
clap are you done now you're done now
chair really okay silly Willy
I know dear diary my mommy never wants
to talk about the hidden safe behind the
painting when I found not very hidden
I'm not even allowed to touching the
metal door my mommy says it's not good
to go in there come on kid really really
kid just use some grammar okay
Oh bookshelf in the bedroom manga up
tender facts what to get what is it
stuck hello oh whoa whoa hey got a
winner
oh I get it
can I get it can I get it can I get it
can i I need the hang on excuse me
Gibby oh yes you big beefy cherry you I
need to borrow you for a second my
goodness you do have nice thighs you
could probably crush coconuts in between
those thighs in basement keys why is the
basement door right by the bedroom
that's weird
why show dark down there why don't our
down there oh this is worth it work
oh come on [ __ ] damn it unlock down here
with the worker
ah barrel Oh how'd you get all the way
up there man barrel well was that take
it back
golly hell through that barrel oh man
all right chest
fakie chest chest ha ha
ah come on throw something real at me I
swear it's just fake stuff ah oh come on
seriously
come on sir ah real monsters yeah says
you
anyway ha ha
freak afraid this is a bad place wait
hopefully the monster will come out and
I can sneak by and go inside there yeah
it's great plan great plan
go team go yeah high five
oh there he goes
oh and here I go super stealth super
stealth run run you ass bag kick it that
what's this eh scuse me monster I need
to read last time I saw a little child
another woman they told me there was
something leaking but there's nothing
wrong with it then I went up again but
they locked the door I was stuck in here
I was screaming but they can't hear me
did they leave I've been stuck here for
two days now and everything hurts it
feels almost like my body is
uncontrollable they locked me away for a
reason yeah because you're all haunted
and whatnot what's just something in
here tinder box nothing uh crap
aw crap I'm in
oh ah oh you want some huh it's a
showdown me and you oh yeah oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah all you can't handle ah rock oh
yeah Oh show was this door locked
wait what what you should just stop too
deep oh did he die
oMG did he died the monsters don't seem
to go away in this mod I swear I still
hear the monsters give each ear you're
gonna help block up this do our way yeah
I know the door goes in but still it's
the thought that counts
I got the thought of the thunder-thighs
chair is in there good take on the
monster itself is still brave anyway
okay alright
I
it's a key to unlock a safe to get
another key ah I don't get it all right
whatever I our storage key that's all
that matters and I'm moving forward move
it forward forward forward forward
always forward now where do we go now
number two number two do I need to get a
key to get a CH that would be stupid
okay lad don't that's weird
I would have figured you would get a key
to get eh level but apparently not okay
come on Lodi must be a big level come on
come on
something down there what I got not
enough oil they're giving me the bare
minimum oh boy who's down here hello
nope nope nope
f you know don't they nope to me oh oh
here haha nope
Oh God ah gah what oh okay this place
wants me dead yep
- I'm stuck here so I need to find
explosives to blow these rocks yep
nope yep some notes okay
hello Oh mom
Avery full refill might be a waste but I
still got some oil left okay cool
alright tynda box I can come back
tomorrow if I need it okay so we got a
blue go coming from there and there's
actually Milo alright actually that's
gonna have to wait I am all out of time
we're gonna have to go in this one
obviously this is a trap by the looks of
it but we're gonna have to go in that
place in the next episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye bye